[Music]
my name is jessie dyer and i work here
at l.l bean yellow bean was founded in
1912 by an avid outdoorsman leon liam
wood bean his first creation was the
main hunting shoe that boot most
commonly known as the ll bean boot is
our most iconic product and we've made
this for 110 years if a customer has a
pair of well-worn boots and is not ready
to give them up we can easily re-sew
them and bring them back to like new
condition
in order to replace and put a new bottom
on it we will be removing the upper from
this boot it will go in the saw and we
will start detaching that with the saw
on the blade the boots get clamped they
get put into the saw and it cuts right
down through the bottom of the boot once
the boot comes out of the machine it
does have a piece of the brush guard
that is still attached to the leather we
remove this in order to have the leather
all nice and clean so that it can fit on
the new bottom snug and complete we call
this stripping the boot
[Music]
we use a flat knife as well as scissors
to cut the stitches away from the upper
once this happens we can hand pick all
the stitches that remain behind
[Music]
in order to help us get these stitches
out easier we actually have a rub
machine and this is very much like a
rotating bristle the outside of the
leather boot actually brushes up against
that and it helps loosen the stitches so
that we can pull them out easier and
have a nice clean finish to the leather
upper
[Music]
we then pick out all the threads from
the bottom part of the upper so that it
can be restitched onto the new bottom
nice and clean and not have any
straggling pieces of thread left behind
we're now going to start reassembly
in this step we are actually going to
move the old heel protector and attach a
new one
this particular boot is looking for a
brand new bottom so we were replacing it
with the exact same bottom that the
customer received when they purchased
the boot originally
in order for this to properly attach we
make sure that there is any dust or
debris or stitches that are all removed
once that happens we actually apply
cement to both the new bottom boot as
well as the leather upper
once that is complete we move right onto
the vamping process
[Music]
we have a vamping machine that we've
done and this is all done by hand so
this particular machine will drop three
needles down into the boot with stitches
and complete the stitching process to
the boot bottom
we use great kit to line up the holes at
times this requires slowing down the
machine and really taking a fine look as
to where those holes are
[Music]
once we complete the vamp we move over
to the packing station here is where we
will give it one final look to make sure
that quality is insured
before boxing we make sure that we are
wiping down any debris that could be
left behind
we replace the lace and the inner sole
on each boot just due to wear
we try to get everything right back to
its original status
now that the boots are complete we go to
packing them up and shipping them out to
another happy customer
[Music]
i'm really happy at how these boots came
out and i cannot wait for our customer
to see them
[Music]
bye
[Music]